we are told a teacher bought 12 sheets
of stickers to use on the homework of
her students each sheet had 48 stickers
at the end of the year the teacher had
123 stickers remaining which is the best
estimate for the number of stickers the
teacher used so like always pause this
video and see if you could have a go at
this before we work on this together
alright now let's work on this together
so the first thing to appreciate is we
just have to figure out an estimate we
don't have to figure out the exact
number of the stickers that were used
let's see if we can do that so let's see
we have 12 sheets of stickers and each
sheet had 48 stickers 48 stickers per
sheet so how many stickers did the
teacher start off with well there were
12 sheets times the number of stickers
per sheet so times 48 times 48 this is
going to be the number that they started
off with number to start and then if we
want to figure out the number that are
used we just have to figure out okay
from the number that was started how
many are left over and then that's how
many were used and so how many were left
were left over well 123 were remaining
at the end of the year so that's this
number right over here so if we
calculate that first the number to start
we subtract out the number that are
remaining then that will be equal to the
number of stickers that the teacher used
now once again we don't have to figure
out exactly we just have to estimate and
so I'm just going to try to figure out
friendlier numbers to work with
so instead of 12 let's imagine let's
imagine actually I'll stick with 12 12 I
can work with but let's say that this is
going to be approximately equal to so in
parenthesis instead of 48 I'll say it's
roughly 50 so this is going to be
approximately 12 times 50 instead of 123
I'll say that's roughly a friendlier
number might be a hundred and twenty or
might be a hundred that's just 220 so
minus 100
we could have done a hundred and so we
could figure out what this is in our
heads or with a little bit of paper 12
times 5 is 60 so 12 times 50 is 600 and
then 600 if we had a hundred-year 600
minus 100 movement at 500 or 600 minus
120 is 480 so what we want to do is look
in the choice and see which of these
choices is closest to roughly 500 or
roughly 480 and so let's see out of all
of these actually they have exactly 480
which is so they estimated exactly the
way we happen to estimate now not every
person is going to do that we could have
two chosen instead of hundred 23
becoming 120 in our estimate we could
have put a hundred there and then we
would have gotten 500 but even if 500
was our estimate 480 still would have
been the closest to that estimate